[Música]
gustavo petro toma posesión este domingo
como presidente de colombia y se
convertirá en el primer mandatario de
izquierda en la historia democrática del
país decenas de líderes y delegaciones
mundiales llegaron para el evento
méxico continúa trabajando para rescatar
a los 10 mineros que quedaron atrapados
en una mina de carbón que se inundó en
el estado de coahuila tras un derrumbe
se cumplen más de 72 horas desde el
incidente y todavía no hay avances
claros sobre el agua
en eeuu indiana es el primer estado en
restringir casi de manera total el
derecho al aborto este procedimiento
sólo se permitirá en caso de violación e
incesto y la medida entrará en vigor a
partir del 15 de septiembre
hola y bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en france 24 los
saluda andrés meza muñoz
empezamos en colombia la relación
fronteriza con la vecina venezuela está
cerca de reanudarse con la promesa del
presidente electo gustavo petro que se
posesiona este domingo como mandatario
de restablecer los lazos diplomáticos y
económicos con el gobierno de nicolás
maduro los comerciales y empresarios ven
en este nuevo tiempo un camino de
esperanza para retomar sus actividades
comerciales entre ambas naciones
marta moya con los detalles
resurge la esperanza en la frontera
entre colombia y venezuela la empresa de
transporte de alfredo rosales y sus
hermanos trabajaba a pleno rendimiento
hasta que en 2015 el gobierno de nicolás
maduro cerró los pasos fronterizos con
su vecina colombia tras el deterioro de
las relaciones bilaterales entonces
dejaron de transportar anualmente casi
un millón de toneladas de harina carbón
cemento y otras mercancías ahora con la
promesa del presidente colombiano
gustavo petro de normalizar las
relaciones y reanudar la actividad
comercial binacional los empresarios
tienen esperanza de recuperar sus
camiones y volver a la carretera de ver
unos carros que han producido que han
trabado tanto y verlo ahí arriba o
pudriéndose
desechando se sólo como se pueden ver
estos carros
gente que llegue
la apertura de la frontera otra vez a
querer a salir adelante de repente hay
un ánimo chico entiende aunque el
optimismo es contenido y en el terreno
saben que la situación no cambiará
drásticamente de la noche a la mañana
después del periodo del conservador iván
duque ahora se abre un nuevo tiempo
después de más de un lustro de tensiones
la semana que viene ya deberíamos tener
en principio empezar a circular aunque
sea de manera simbólica alguno vehículo
porque esa señal en la que va a permitir
que los empresarios empiecen a voltear
al otro lado a ver qué es lo que pueden
comprar del otro lado de reactivar las
autoridades venezolanas estiman que si
la apertura fronteriza se hace efectiva
este mismo año la actividad económica
entre ambas naciones podría alcanzar los
1.200 millones de dólares
el propósito de este tema los invitamos
a que nos acompañen este domingo en el
cubrimiento especial de la posesión del
nuevo presidente de colombia gustavo
petro a partir de las 3 de la tarde hora
de bogotá quito y lima
seguimos en colombia las intensas
lluvias azotan el occidente del país
provocando deslizamientos de tierra unas
160 viviendas fueron destruidas dejando
unas 60 familias sin hogar en el
municipio de bello departamento de
antioquia entre fuertes corrientes de
agua y calles completamente llenas de
lodo algunos residentes tratan de
recuperar sus pertenencias hasta el
momento las autoridades no reportan
víctimas
y el mandatario peruano pedro castillo
intenta evitar una nueva crisis en su
gabinete y por ello rechazó la renuncia
del presidente del consejo de ministros
aníbal torres pues de irse tendría que
cambiar todos los líderes de la cartera
sin embargo castillo si cambio a seis
funcionarios todo en medio de las cinco
investigaciones por presunta corrupción
que adelanta la fiscalía en su contra
rafael pérez nos cuenta más
un respiro al menos temporal para el
presidente de perú al no aceptar la
renuncia del primer ministro aníbal
torres el presidente pedro castillo
esquiva un nuevo voto de confianza del
congreso torres alegó motivos personales
para poner a disposición su cargo si la
renuncia del premier hubiese sido
aceptada habría sido el cuarto primer
ministro en abandonar el puesto en 13
meses de gobierno de castillo sin
embargo hubo un importante movimiento en
el gabinete como nuevas incorporaciones
destacan miguel rodríguez como canciller
kurt burneo ex ministro en el gobierno
de ollanta humala en el ministerio de
economía
betsy chávez en la cartera de cultura y
césar paniagua quien jura como encargado
del ministerio de vivienda construcción
y saneamiento otros simplemente se
mudaron de oficina alejandro salas quien
deja el ministerio de cultura y pasa al
trabajo y gamer alvarado quien deja el
ministerio del trabajo y asume como
ministro del transporte y comunicaciones
la oposición arremetió con críticas nos
sumió en una nueva crisis con la
renuncia de torres para complicarnos más
con sus designados por perú
la agenda de trabajo continúa sin
contratiempos el dignatario se mostró
este fin de semana junto a su jefe de
gabinete en medio de las denuncias de
corrupción que caen sobre castillo las
relaciones del mandatario con el
congreso no pasa por su mejor momento en
una decisión sin presidentes el
hemiciclo decidió no otorgar permiso al
jefe de estado para participar esta
semana en la toma de posición del nuevo
presidente colombiano actualmente son
cinco las investigaciones penales
abiertas contra el castillo mientras se
suman los llamados a un juicio político
en mexico el gobierno de andrés manuel
lópez obrador calificó el sábado de día
clave para poder encontrar a los diez
mineros atrapados en una instalación de
carbón tras un derrumbe los equipos de
rescate tratan de vaciar de agua a los
pozos inundados y las familias tienen la
esperanza de que sus seres queridos
pudieran esconderse
desesperación y esperanza de la mano en
méjico después de tres días bajo tierra
se agotan las horas para poder encontrar
a los diez mineros con los que no se ha
establecido contacto mientras avanzan
las tareas de rescate
[Música]
durante un trabajo de excavación en una
mina de carbón del estado de coahuila la
pared de un túnel se derrumbó y tres
pozos se inundaron los equipos de
emergencia tratan de sacar el agua para
que puedan entrar los buzos que dan
esperanzas de que los mineros podrían
haberse escondido en bolsas de aire
después tenemos la esperanza todavía de
que ellos estén en algún parte una parte
alta por ahí en
aunque es demasiada agua estaba hasta
arriba el pozo desde la gobernación de
coahuila se culpa a los dueños de la
mina de una mala planeación uno de ellos
se comprometió a colaborar con la
investigación yo creo que la prioridad
número uno es ahorita respetarlos y
llegar a las autoridades que investiguen
y que hagan su trabajo
y así como están hablando si creen que
yo soy responsable este
que se haga lo que se tenga que hacer
méxico tiene un largo historial de
accidentes de este tipo en junio de 2021
también en coahuila murieron siete
mineros en el colapso de otra
instalación de extracción de carbón
vamos a cuba- un muerto y más de 100
heridos dejó un grave incendio en los
depósitos de combustible en la ciudad de
matanzas el siniestro inició el viernes
cuando un rayo golpeó uno de los tanques
lo que desató el fuego que luego se
extendió a un segundo depósito este
sábado varios países ofrecieron su ayuda
para extinguir las llamas y el
presidente miguel díaz canel dijo que la
tarea podría tardar debido a la gravedad
de la conflagración
en eeuu indiana se convirtió en el
primer estado en restringir casi
totalmente la interrupción del embarazo
después de que la corte suprema de
justicia anulara el histórico fallo del
roe versus wade el senado estatal de
mayoría republicana aprobó la reforma el
viernes y poco después el gobernador del
estado la firmó la administración de
bailén condenó el hecho diciendo que es
otro intento extremo de los republicanos
sitio 62 a favor 38 en contra la ley
está aprobada
indian ahora el primer estado de los
eeuu en aprobar una prohibición casi
total del aborto desde que se derogó
robersis white la cámara mayoría
republicana votó a favor de la propuesta
de ley del senado aprobando las
restricciones a la interrupción del
embarazo la prohibición que entra en
vigor el 15 de septiembre permitirá el
aborto sólo en casos de violación o
incesto siempre y cuando se realice
dentro de las 10 semanas después de la
fecundación sólo los hospitales podrán
realizar el procedimiento que significa
que todas las clínicas de aborto en el
estado perderán sus licencias indiana
empezó a debatir leyes de aborto más
estrictas poco después de junio cuando
la corte suprema- votó para eliminar la
protección constitucional al
procedimiento los habitantes expresaron
sus opiniones sobre este tema es tan
importante que respetamos el derecho de
las mujeres para tomar sus propias
decisiones sobre la base de sus propias
creencias y circunstancias
yo soy cristiana yo veo a mucha gente
que no tiene esperanza y estoy rezando
por ellos
el debate se exentó cuando una niña de
10 años víctimas de violación viajo del
estado vecino ohio para terminar su
embarazo a causa de la llamada
prohibición por latido fetal indiana
ahora es el primer estado en aprobar
legislación anti aborto en ambas
cámaras- pero en el estado republicano
de kansas la votación se sometió a los
residentes en un referéndum que votaron
a favor de la libertad reproductiva sólo
cuatro estados más incluyendo california
michigan vermont y canto aquí también se
preparan para un voto popular en
noviembre
hasta aquí es informativo gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]